don't get married
till you drop
and then just buy okay so it says have
sex till you drop and then just buy a
house don't get married do that I love
this and the reason that I love it is
because it's just quintessential bad
relationship advice you are inevitably
when you're in a relationship with
someone you don't want to get married
well either there are two two
possibilities one possibility is that
the relationship will just dissolve very
quickly because there's no end point in
mind there's no reason there's no reason
for this relationship to exist it's a
trip with no with no kind of destination
in mind where are we going I don't know
and uh people aren't going to stay on
that trip for very long the other
possible endpoint is that it dissolves
later on in the in the meantime it
begins to emulate marriage it start you
start taking on a lot of the external
landmarks of of marriage but without the
marriage there you move in you buy a
house you have you share a mortgage you
do all these things which it looks a lot
like marriage but it is